hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol
ac.l2-3-1.16 you got that right
authorized wireless access prior to
allowing such connections
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp80171 compliant stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you've
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmmc control
ac.l2-3.1.16 authorized wireless access
prior to allowing such connections what
does this mean what does it mean well it
means no open wireless networks are
allowed you have to have a password
token Etc but you just can't have open
wireless networks all right we're
talking about cui here even if you have
a big giant secure building that
controls mandate that authentication is
required let's check out what the ask
what the assessors are looking for and
how to make them happy on this one
so if I'm an assessor the first thing
I'm looking for is one determine if
wireless access points are identified
are they of course they are right
there's an SSID wireless network
controller system identifies all
wireless access points including both
authorized and unauthorized that's a
good sample answer so who knows maybe
you're using a ubiquity system or a
Cisco system and that system's
identifying the wireless access points
might also be good if you've got
something to detect Rogue access points
as well now the second thing that
they're looking for is determining if
wireless access is authorized prior to
allowing such Connections in other words
did somebody or something authorize you
to actually get that wireless access now
if I was going to create a sample answer
I might say something like no wireless
access is possible without authorization
via input of a secure password or maybe
a token or something like that
so uh and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this D fars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to Landing more Defense
work with higher profit margins now
that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you because CMC compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliances roll it out until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us up in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
all right